hey 42 here
every so often news of an impending
apocalypse hits the global headlines
sometimes rumors of these imminent end
times come from the translated writings
of an ancient civilization sometimes
they crop up in the ramblings of a
sociopathic cult leader
and sometimes they're in highly
interpreted quotes from prophecies made
by the likes of nostradamus or babavanga
wherever they come from these
predictions all have one thing in common
not a single one of them has ever come
true
obviously
no matter what fiery death is promised
or by whom the world keeps on turning
and the sun continues to rise
that's all very reassuring but
unfortunately that reassurance is
completely false
because
and i'm really sorry to be the one to
have to tell you this
the world actually is coming to an end
don't worry i haven't decided to start
my own doomsday cult
the impending earthly apocalypse i'm
referring to here is actually a
scientific certainty
our world is ending and if we fail to
act the human race will die
that's the bad news i thought i'd get it
out of the way first
the good news is we have quite a long
time to get our plans for survival in
place before any existential feces
impacts to spinning mechanical
ventilation system it's a strange
paradox that whilst we aren't all that
great at predicting what the weather
will be like in a month or even a week
from now
we know with a fairly high degree of
certainty what will happen in our
universe millions or even billions of
years in the future that's because
modern science has reached a
sufficiently advanced level that we can
accurately simulate important
cosmological processes like the life
cycle of stars and the ultimate fate of
black holes
using that information we know exactly
how long we have left before the real
life apocalypse arrives and earth is no
longer habitable by humans
it's about a billion years but more on
that in a second
the trouble is having this information
isn't all that useful to us
you see we humans are naturally
short-termist
the global average life expectancy
stands at just shy of 73 years
as your friendly neighborhood oap will
no doubt tell you
that isn't a very long time which is
probably why as a species we tend to
live in the moment we care about
ourselves our families our friends our
children and grandchildren but our
distant descendants 100 200 a thousand
years from now
screw those high-tech bastards
but the fact of the matter is we're
standing on the cusp of an incredible
opportunity
from what we can see so far we seem to
have this little corner of the universe
pretty much to ourselves
that should give us the time and space
to spread out a bit and make ourselves
properly comfy
if we're able to do that we'll soon find
ourselves in a pretty remarkable
position
with human colonies spread light years
apart throughout the galaxy
our species will become extremely
resilient to all known forms of
existential threat things like famine
and disease are meaningless on a
galactic scale
and wars pretty much can't be waged when
travel times between stars are measured
in thousands of years
sure we may one day have to worry about
unfriendly neighbours but the universe
is big and getting bigger so there's no
guarantee we'll ever meet anyone else up
close if we don't and if spreading out a
bit makes us effectively unkillable in
all the traditional ways that we're
familiar with there's every reason to
believe the human race could survive for
a very very long time
millions of years perhaps billions
trillions
it's genuinely possible that you and i
are amongst the early pioneers of a
civilization that will stand as the
universe itself collapses around us
untold eons in the future
okay so maybe i'm just getting a touch
ahead of myself but my point still
stands if we humans are able to make it
through these awkward teenage years of
acne and atomic bombs
and that's a big if
who knows how far we could go there are
certainly some hefty challenges standing
in our way though the first of which
will be getting the hell off this death
trap we call earth as of today every
single human being alive is currently on
or near the surface of our home planet
from a project planning perspective you
have to admit it's a bit of a disaster i
mean seriously who's in charge here
for now all it would take to bring up
humanity's collective game over screen
is an errant asteroid a well-aimed
coronal mass ejection a nuclear war or a
particularly nasty pandemic nice try by
the way covered
any of these things could spell the end
of homo sapiens in the coming centuries
but for the purpose of this video i want
to think a bit bigger
so let's just assume we get our act
together and sort all that stuff out
that we get over all our differences and
start trying to kill each other figure
out how to deflect or destroy any
asteroids and managed to shield our
infrastructure from any [ __ ] the sun
sends our way
if we do all of that then we have about
a billion years of safety left to us
here on earth
that's a pretty long time about 5000
times longer than our species has
existed so far
but we can't afford to faff around
because when that billion years is up
planet earth will experience an actual
honest-to-god apocalypse
as our sun ages it will slowly grow
larger and brighter increasing in
luminosity at a rate of about one
percent every 100 million years or so a
billion years from now the sun will be
releasing about 10 percent more energy
than it does today leading to
catastrophic global warming that will
eventually see surface temperatures on
our lush home planet hit a frankly
uncomfortable
350 degrees celsius
boiling away the oceans and making the
atmosphere unbreathable but whilst an
expanding sun will do terrible things
for housing prices here on earth estate
agents over on mars will be having a
field day as the sun grows hotter our
solar system's habitable zone the range
of orbits in which a planet could
support liquid water on its surface will
be pushed further outwards
making the previously frigid mars where
surface temperatures are about minus 60
degrees celsius today a much more
palatable proposition
particularly when you consider the fact
that there are more than 5 million cubic
kilometers of ice on mars's surface just
waiting to be melted into lovely deep
oceans
not that we can let the sun do all the
work there would still be plenty of
manual terraforming to be done the
atmosphere would need to be made
breathable for one thing but a billion
years should be enough time to get all
of those little details ironed out mars
will only ever be a temporary stop
though as the sun continues to grow
larger brighter and hotter
even mars will one day be too toasty for
us humans to handle
four singles to seek sanctuary deeper
and deeper into the solar system
the gas giants are unlikely to ever make
good homes for humans but several of
their moons mind europa which orbits
jupiter is fought to hide a vast ocean
beneath its icy surface that holds three
times as much water as all of earth's
oceans combined
so that might be a good place to start
and when europa gets too hot saturn's
moon tighten the only moon in the solar
system that has a dense atmosphere like
earth
might be our next step
but eventually there will come a time
where nowhere in our solar system is
safe anymore
five billion years from now our sun will
have used up its supply of hydrogen
entirely
at which point it will enter the red
giant phase of its evolution as a red
giant the sun will grow to truly
mind-boggling proportions about 250
times its current size
large enough to swallow the orbits of
mercury venus and earth entirely the sun
won't ever go supernova it's too small
for that but it will eventually render
the entirety of our solar system
uninhabitable and that will be our cue
to leave
with the ancestral home of humanity
essentially dead to us
the next task on the agenda will be to
find another star with some nice
non-vaporized planets where we can make
ourselves a new home
but here's a catch
as of today 95 of all the stars that
will ever exist in our universe have
already been born
and 5 billion years from now when we're
in search of a new home
many of them will have already reached
the end of their life cycles
just like our sun
luckily not all stars age at the same
speed somewhat counterintuitively the
smaller a star is the longer its life
span
because whilst large stars contain more
hydrogen fuel they burn it far more
quickly than smaller ones do
our sun is a mid-sized yellow dwarf with
a lifespan of about 10 billion years
the smallest class of main sequence
stars the red dwarfs have an average
lifespan of several trillion years
meaning they'll live hundreds of times
longer than the universe has existed so
far
if we can find ourselves a nice small
red dwarf to live near we could set
ourselves up without any major dramas
for the next 10 trillion years or so
that's a very long time so long that
it's actually pretty hard for our puny
human minds to comprehend it
we throw these kinds of numbers around a
lot billion trillion without ever really
appreciating just how vast they are if
you were to count to a million one
second at a time non-stop it would take
you about 11 days
that's a long time to spend counting but
probably just doable with the help of
some intravenous red bull so how long do
you think it would take to count to a
billion in the same way
one number per second
a few weeks six months
try 31 years
and counting to a trillion would take
more than 31 000 years
as luck would have it the nearest star
to our solar system proxima centauri
just so happens to be a red dwarf with
trillions of years in the tongue
so we won't have to go far when the
solar system apocalypse finally arrives
of course not far is relative on a
galactic scale proxima centauri is about
4.2 light years away
that's 24.5 trillion miles
using today's technology that kind of
journey is quite literally impossible it
would take tens of thousands of years
even with our fastest ships and we'd
need to build something the size of a
small city to house a colony large
enough to make the journey without
inbreeding itself to death still several
billions of years of now the chances are
good that we'd be up to the task
but even the red dwarfs won't last
forever in 100 trillion years all the
excess hydrogen in existence will have
been consumed and star formation in our
universe will cease altogether
one by one the final stars ever to shine
will begin to wink out
if human beings do manage to make it
this far it's safe to say it's going to
be a pretty bloody scary time with
everything slowly fading to black around
us
but as unnerving as it will no doubt be
there is a way to turn the lights back
on at least temporarily
bashing brown dwarfs together like giant
conkers
naturally
brown dwarfs are commonly referred to as
failed stars because they're too small
to do star things like fuse hydrogen in
their cores but large enough to do
distinctly unplanty things like fuse
lithium and deuterium
brown dwarfs emit almost no visible
light and so wouldn't make useful
replacement suns
but they do contain all the rare
ingredients needed for a genuine star
all they lack is the mass to create core
temperatures hot enough to ignite
hydrogen fusion with our 100 trillion
years in the future technology we should
simply be able to whiz about the galaxy
scooping up brown dwarfs and mashing
them together to form proper
hydrogen-fusing stars it's thought that
this process will occasionally occur
naturally for about the next quintillion
years or so
creating handfuls of impossibly remote
stars alone in the vastness of the ever
universe
okay by now we really are getting
absurdly far into the future and the
truth is we don't actually know for sure
whether our universe will still even
exist at that point i mentioned at the
start of this video that modern science
can see deep into the future
and that's true to a certain extent but
it's also kind of not true
we know quite a lot about star life
cycles and black holes
but as yet we don't really know when the
universe will end or even how and our
best estimates as to the when parts vary
so wildly as to be almost meaningless
the universe might end in 22 billion
years in a so-called big rip that sees
dark matter tear space-time apart
or it might end in significantly more
than a google years
that's a one with 100 zeroes after it
when the universe reaches a state of
thermal equilibrium known as heat death
whichever one of these cheery scenarios
marks the end of
well everything
even that doesn't necessarily have to be
the final page in the never-ending story
of humanity
though surviving beyond the end of the
universe would certainly require
technology so advanced that as arthur c
clarke would say it would seem like
magic to us today
if we did have access to some serious
techno magic
perhaps we could use it to counter the
expansionary forces of dark energy to
prevent the big risk or maybe we could
use it to somehow trade our wrinkly old
universe in for a sexier younger model
by traveling into a parallel world
only time will tell like a lot of time
you may think it's a bit ridiculous to
even consider our species surviving to
the very end of the universe considering
the sorry state of things here on earth
today and uh yeah it is
right now our species faces undoubtedly
its most dangerous period since we were
just a bunch of defenseless apes first
figuring out all the cool things we
could do with sticks
war is an ever-present threat the
climate is constantly doing weird things
and space threatens us with catastrophes
that we simply have no way of dealing
with right now but if we do somehow
manage to pass through this bottleneck
the great filter if that's what it is
there really is no reason why our
species can't go on to found a dynasty
that stands for thousands of years
and perhaps much
longer
[Music]
as far as i'm concerned it's worth a
shot
thanks for watching